[Music]
[Applause]
brady quinn fox sports college and nfl
studio and game analyst and he of course
is on the two pros and a cup of joe
radio show alongside labar arrington and
jonas knox you can catch them on fox
sports radio weekdays 6 to 9 a.m eastern
which leads right into our show brady
joins us on the program good morning
brady how are you
i'm doing well let me just say this
mclovin i'll miss you
sad to see you leave um but you know
everyone's gotta gotta move on at some
point you know
well you were cut you know you've got
yeah yeah so you know what the feeling
is like when the team that you're with
doesn't really want you around anymore
yeah yeah no and uh you know like like i
told you last week you know i had a nice
little discussion with my realtor who
was really upset about the whole
situation the landlord but uh no i
it's uh it's uh you know
sometimes it could be a blessing in
disguise you know when you get cut
do you get to grab your jersey and take
your jersey
no no no and and the worst part is is
there's like a sentence that's said and
then everyone knows what's going to
happen next
it's usually
coach wants to see you bring your
playbook with you
um and i learned that when i first
signed and agreed to my rookie deal with
the browns
and i remember walking the locker room
and as soon as i'm walking in
i heard one of our uh scouts that had
gone and said something to like one of
the players
and at that point in time i didn't
really didn't understand like what was
happening
but like literally that transaction was
just taking place
and so that guy was getting cut to make
move on the right you know make room on
the roster for me to be there
and i i've never forgotten that
that sentence and that's why i always
tell like i tell players like young kids
this all the time because you know
football doesn't last for everyone but
it's a great
game that teaches you a lot about life
and so regardless of what level you know
it ends for you just take your playbook
with you uh so try to take it you know
create like a positive spin on something
that's pretty negative
all right a couple of things here uh
before i talk about what's going on with
the college football playoff committee
and the possibility of forfeitures in
the national playoffs how about this the
team that should stick with its
quarterback miami
indy
philly
the niners washington
uh what for next year i mean what's the
context of the question yeah
like you're set at the position
i honestly i feel like all of them with
the exception of washington and and
washington's like the interesting one to
me where
i think you you go back before the
season
and you're i'm still kind of questioning
like so what was the plan like brian
fitzpatrick was going to be the guy and
that was just
how it was going to go and yeah maybe
they battle for the nfc east maybe not
but i i just given his age and and
what's their what's their stealing if
that's if that's the decision you're
making
you know so i never really understood
that whole plan to begin with
and so that's the one thing like one
team assuredly that i can tell you is
gonna be looking for a quarterback
in the offseason the rest of them i
think they've all got young guys
who i think you need to give more more
time to yeah but you gotta move on from
jimmy
garoppolo
you know i
i look at that situation though just
from the small
windows we had to see trey lansin he's
not ready
and and and garoppolo still has a year
left
on his deal now granted they can release
him and i think the dead cat's like 1.4
or something like that
but that might be a scenario where and
i'm not trying to compare jimmy
garoppolo to aaron rodgers
but you know we saw jordan love
initially like all right
he needs a little more work too he needs
some more development too trey lance is
a similar boat and as long as jimmy
garoppolo is healthy
he plays a winning style of football you
know you can't take that away from him
he's accurate he doesn't really turn on
the football too much he's not going to
buy time and create a bunch of plays and
all that but
he's he's able to help you know this
team win football games and so i just i
don't see a reason to move on from him
so fast
especially considering some of the bad
years that kyle shanahan and john lynch
have experienced like do you really want
to go through those groin pains again
yeah with a younger quarterback just
because where you drafted them
well i look at philly and and i like
jalen hurts i just think they have to
decide if they're going to build around
him uh indy they can't get out from
underneath carson wentz's contract right
now miami i'd have second thoughts about
making that trade for deshaun watson
because you can use those draft picks
and make yourself a better team and i
think tua has played well enough to
maybe hold on to that
the niners eventually they have to move
on with garoppolo and trey lance in the
uh on deck circle in washington
certainly so
i philly might be the one team that i
would say out of all of them like it
feels like they're a little more set
than anybody else
i feel like every single one of those
situations with their quarterback though
is unique like one of the things i'll
say about jalen hurts from following him
from alabama to oklahoma and then to the
nfl is
that young man's gotten better and
better and better the more he's played
and i really thought he took a jump from
the frustrations that we would hear from
nick saban in the spring game when he's
micked up you know about you know
throwing the football not playing more
from the pocket to then doing that in
oklahoma to a degree and then continuing
to get better at that at the nfl level
i just think he's the type of kid that
the more he plays the better he's going
to get and i think he likes challenges i
think he likes you know the way nick
syriana him the rapport they have
and so he's the type of guy that even if
you do build out around him and you find
out two years from now like what a
ceiling is it's just not for you
you know you're still going to have that
team set up though for whoever the next
guy is going to be to have success
you know then you look at miami you know
the way to tango by law was handled last
year and this year
i just don't know how you can sit there
and look at it and say like he's you've
really gotten a clear picture of you
know what he's capable of being because
he kept jerking him in and out and it
never made any sense to me last year and
the offensive line that they've rebuilt
is finally starting to mesh a little bit
better but you know by in large part
they haven't had much of a consistent
running game
and so you know his accuracy is
obviously one of the best in the league
he's been able to make some plays i know
people talk about not having the
strongest arm but you can still make all
the throws
so i i'm kind of more of a believer too
and just seeing what he is at least next
year unless
you really do feel like you can get
a better quarterback via a trade
and whether it's deshawn watson or
anyone else but obviously with deshaun
watson there's a lot of potential
baggage that could come along with that
and that's obviously the risk i think
for any team that's look and say all
right can we get better than this or
should we continue to build it with what
we have
four rookies made the pro bowl if we
re-drafted
what order would they go in micah
parsons jamar chase kyle pitts rashaan
slater
i mean are we putting a premium on the
position
because yeah i mean the thing about
michael parsons as good as he's been
this year is like dallas locked into
that position right do the injuries and
all that so if he could redraft it he's
probably going first overall yeah with
the way he played
now
i mean maybe that sounds like it's um
maybe that sounds like controversial to
a degree but the reality is you could
put him up for defensive player of the
year and he he might win it i don't know
there's there's been any player that's
impacted a team or at least a side of
the football more so than micah parsons
this year so i think you would be the
first one you take off the board yeah i
agree later
or sean slater doesn't get enough credit
cause he's a tackle yeah you know we
don't we don't look at what he does and
we say oh like this guy has been playing
at a high level he's been as good as
probably most tackles in the league this
year as a rookie so i'd probably say
second and especially when you've got a
guy like herbert he's protecting you
know chase would probably be third i
think he's been everything
that was advertised advertised and um
you know who's the fourth
uh kyle pitts
yeah i mean
the problem is as good as pitts has been
at the tight end position
you know that team just got so many
issues so many holes and it's gonna be
hard for him to turn things around but
to me between chase and pitts i think
chase has had the bigger impacts for the
two pass catchers talking to brady quinn
uh former notre dame quarterback nfl
quarterback and of course works for fox
sports i'm trying to figure out this
college football playoff policy that was
uh written this week uh why they're
putting it out now kind of boxes them
them in but
uh you know they're talking about if one
of the four semi-finalists is unable to
participate because of a covet outbreak
the unavailable team will forfeit its
opponent will advance to the national
championship
if both teams are unavailable to play in
a semi-final game it would be declared a
no contest then the winner of the other
semifinal game would be declared the
national champion the
i guess you know the national title game
is january 10th and it can be pushed
back to no later than january 14th
are they trying to scare these teams
these players like what get give me the
logic uh behind this
i i don't know i don't know there's much
logic to it i mean i think maybe
cincinnati's somewhere hoping and
praying that everyone gets covered
the champion right
i mean
that's that's the only thing that makes
sense to me in this whole thing but
um the reality is i don't know why they
just can't
reschedule or push it back
um i i get their semi-final bowl games
there's a lot that goes into the
preparation for these it's not like
you know your typical regular season
game there's a lot more that goes into
it the hotels and the people flying in
and everything how it's booked
like i understand all of that but there
has to be some degree of this is for a
national championship you know we we'd
like this thing to play itself out and i
also wonder like what that burden is
where a team decides it's going to
declare it's going to have to forfeit
because of covet cases this isn't the
nfl you have more than 46 active players
that can play in a game right you've got
what 85 scholarship players on most
teams whatever the case is but 100
players in the team you can field a team
it just may not be all your starters if
that ends up being the case so
i i'm not sure really what the point is
outside of maybe motivating all the
teams to get boosters but
even in that event i don't know that
that that provides them any additional
protection like we see with the nfl
where if players are vast
if they're asymptomatic they're not
going to get tested it's only if they're
tested yeah if they were implementing a
policy similar to that then it would
make sense to you know sense for me to
say okay
like you know some of these teams i
think michigan is going to get boo
they're all going to get boosters
together as a team well if they're
incentivized to do so because
look as long as the kids are
asymptomatic they're going to let them
play that'd be one thing but to the best
of my knowledge that hasn't been a
statement that they've made so
i i'm not sure if they just feel like
because of all the dues coming out with
this particular variant that they're
saying we need to get it out there what
our plans are so people aren't shocked
by it
maybe that's part of it but i i just you
know i'll be really curious to see if
these teams can kind of hold on or if
cincinnati somehow ends up not even have
to play another game winning a national
championship which would be
pretty interesting to see that you know
the reaction to that
who's your pick to win it all
well i think bryce young
which i've been kind of pounding the
pavement for him all year he he's one of
the best quarterback talents like i've
ever seen
um and so it's hard to pick against
bama just for that reason wait wait wait
would you put bryce in there with joe
burrow and justin herbert and like how
as as far as talent-wise yes
like the types of throws he can make
and how he plays the game
as a young player in college football is
unbelievable i i said it before the year
started i said i told everyone back in
the spring
to take the betting advice he's gonna
win the heisman here's the other one
he's gonna be the first two-time heisman
winner now the only thing that would
stand his way is an injury or if he just
decides to balance after next year
that's that's really it
because i think he's talented enough to
win too i don't know if he'll be in
college football long enough to do it
but he's that good of a player
um and so it's hard to pick against bama
and their track work and all that for
for that reason
but my anticipation is you're going to
see georgia and alabama play off again
for the national championship unless
everyone gets coveted um and i think
it's gonna be hard to beat a team twice
and i think that's where you maybe see
georgia finally
get over the hump and and they end up
winning the national championships when
it's all said and done but
i i just it's hard to bet against that
kid the way he moves around the pocket
the way he can create plays utilizes
legs he's as accurate as as you'll see
so i'm a huge bryce young fan i'm sure
you can tell
brady thanks as always uh merry
christmas to the family and uh we'll
talk to you in the new year
yep merry christmas to you and yours
thanks for having me thanks buddy that's
brady quinn from fox sports uh he
co-hosts the radio show two pros and a
cup of joe the show that precedes hours
in fox sports radio